beastmode chocolate bars oh that's right
huh that's right how did you forget
because I came kick it with my boy from
Oakland you know I thought we were just
howling but yeah so we do and we have
something this is the new beast mode
yeah another chocolate bar we do we got
we got we got something special there is
you know a chocolate bar that I'll be
launching on Friday
it's sugar in a em reveal but today we
got something special there is one
chocolate bar under one of the other
seats out there would it go take it like
on some Willy Wonka type so so whoever
find that you feel me you get the
company this guy win then okay so uh
what you do is you win a trip to Seattle
where we actually made the chocolate to
tour the factory with me and I'm where
you at bro
[Applause]
stand up dr. Soong yeah he can't see it
can you open it - I want to see the gold
ticket I want to see if it's really like
on some Willy Wonka type you don't want
to open it wait you got
[Music]
[Applause]
she wouldn't know that what this guy's
nuts to sell it he's like yeah I got I
want to open it I'm coming to get my
damn chocolate
[Applause]
I'll get one please yeah there you go
[Applause]
Willy Wonka fan aren't you yeah I'm
talking about
yeah man rest in peace yeah I just like
that I never thought our segment would
ever end with you and I wearing these
hats hey check this out laser venom in
every beast mode bar purchase will
result in a contribution to marshawn's
families first Family Foundation
well first I'm a set fan family can take
to find out where to get them and to
watch the full video of March done
working at a Chocolate Factory
you got to check it out there too
Marshawn Lynch you're the best thank you
so much
[Applause]
you